hatte um 17 uhr einen termin bei ihm
bei ihm ist ein Architekt wegen a
unbeweglich
Ich dachte, l 5 Rivas und ihn zu tun
dieses Datum und ich ging nach Hause
stattdessen zufällig nur eine ankommende gesehen
Doctor 2 Autobot Speere persönliche Götter
Gewerkschaften, mir die Nachricht zu geben, dass
Retter nicht mehr zu drehen und von der für
Für mich ist jetzt die ganze Welt zusammengebrochen
Herr Zorn, das sage ich immer
verfluchte Galerie
Ich sage verdammt
Auf diesem Foto bin ich bei dem Wagen, mit dem er ausgefahren ist
die särge von salvatore andrea einer von
das ist mein Sohn
er sagte, zwei Monate zu arbeiten sei
Den letzten Tag von uns hatten wir beendet
Arbeit, aber er sagt ihm immer, nein
Ich wollte, dass sie zur Arbeit gehen
deine Mutter ist nicht gefährlich, wir müssen es nur
Reinigen Sie Ihren Geist, benutzen Sie ihn nicht
der Zug kam von hier
sind die Arbeiter, die dies tun
Stationäre Reinigungswagenausgabe
die letzten beiden Waggons sind ausgefahren
Irgendwas im Austausch hat nicht funktioniert
Einige Maßnahmen wurden nicht ergriffen
Sicherheit wurden sowieso nicht genommen
Ich kenne die Autoreifen vorne
zu sagen, dass es Locken sind, die schädlich sind
die bremsen funktionieren bei mir auch nicht
Autofahrt das gleiche, unter das ich mich gestellt habe
jemandem kann ich keine Vaterschaft sagen
lass uns einen Kerl wie alle anderen geben
mit dem großen Wunsch, als Abschied zu leben
Dinge so viele Träume für mich, er war ein guter
Junge
Es gibt einen großen Wunsch, viele Träume zu leben
so viele Dinge zu erreichen, die immer noch geliebt wurden
Leben wie all dies darin gesehen wird
Foto ist nicht so sehr
morgens wache ich auf oder denke an ihn
Geh und lies in Gedanken, ich vermisse ihn
legen Sie Manga und alle